[Music]
you might have seen the matrix but can
you explain the sixth cycle of
humanity's enslavement by the machines
we couldn't either till we made this
guide
in the aftermath of the lengthy machine
war ai has conquered humanity but
they've also become dependent on humans
heat and bioelectricity as a renewable
energy source
a program called the architect is
assigned to create a simulated reality
called the matrix to imprison human
minds and keep their bodies healthy the
architect first develops a simulated
paradise but the humans discover it's
fabricated and rejected to their death a
more realistic simulation is then
created based on earth's real history
and set at humanity's peak in the late
20th century
however prisoners still don't properly
acclimate
enter the oracle a new intuitive program
that analyzes human behavior
the oracle theorizes that humans may be
more likely to accept the matrix's
reality if given a choice
even a subconscious one
this function leads to nearly 99 of all
subjects accepting the simulation
this update stabilizes the matrix for a
hundred years but the collective
disbelief of the remaining one to two
percent of human minds has the potential
to erode the consensus reality and kill
everyone inside
to navigate this issue the matrix
compiles the anomalies caused by
disbelievers until they reach a critical
mass then dumps them all into a single
randomly selected human mind
this individual would have unparalleled
control over the reality of the matrix
but the machines have a plan to deal
with them
a hundred years after the birth of the
first stable matrix a human is born who
recognizes they live in a simulation
this person is able to manipulate the
simulation at will
this individual frees minds from the
matrix and forms a resistance against
the machines in the real world
the freed humans build the underground
city of zion and call their liberator
the one what they don't know is that
without the reintegration of the extra
code that resides within the one the
matrix will collapse killing the
majority of the human race
as a remedy the oracle manifests inside
the matrix and positions herself as an
ally who can use her gift of foresight
to help the one free humanity and end
the machine war
the oracle leads the one to the
architect who offers them a grim choice
either reinsert the extra code they
carry into the source and allow the
matrix to reboot safely
or refuse and guarantee its destruction
to raise the stakes even further the
machines invade zion and kill every free
human
meaning the death of the matrix would be
equivalent to human extinction
this leaves the one no choice but to
cooperate
the machines allow the one to free a
handful of humans to repopulate zion and
form a new resistance
these humans operate under the false
belief they were the first to escape
from the matrix the oracle guides this
new generation telling them the one will
be reborn to save the rest of humanity
when they find the next one they bring
him to the oracle and the cycle
continues over and over again no way
no way this is crazy
during the sixth cycle of the matrix
something changes that allows oracle to
help break the cycle and bring an actual
end to humanity's enslavement by the
machines
it's possible that she's tried to
corrupt the architect system before
after all she claims that her role is to
unbalance the matrix
this time the oracle is able to
influence humans to make a different
outcome possible
the future is created by the choices of
individuals and as she says no one can
see past the choice they don't
understand
the oracle understands more than most
but not everything in a cut scene of the
video game enter the matrix the oracle
says the path of the one is made by many
and that everyone has their role to play
including herself the oracle isn't
certain her plan will work even in the
very end
like everyone else she's forced to act
on faith that a peaceful end to the war
is possible
by the sixth incarnation it becomes
commonplace for members of the
resistance to visit the oracle to ask
her about their purpose
when young morpheus seeks the oracle's
council she tells him he's destined to
find the one
morpheus scours the matrix for signs of
the one with great confidence
the oracle tells trinity a member of
morpheus crew that she'll fall in love
with a man and that he would be the one
trinity reveals this to her cynical
shipmate cipher when morpheus identifies
the hacker neo as potentially being the
one
cipher ridicules trinity about her
feelings as she is indecisive
trinity does indeed fall for neo but
decides to keep this to herself
after training him on how to survive in
the matrix morpheus takes neo to meet
the oracle for the first time
morpheus believes that neo is the one
and that the oracle will confirm this
but neo isn't so sure
neo speaks with the oracle privately
about his doubts
above the entrance to her kitchen reads
the latin phrase timit nosuke which
means know thyself the oracle tells neo
he's not the one unless he knows he's
the one he doesn't believe this about
himself so he assumes that he isn't the
one the oracle lets neo run with that
assumption she also tells him that
morpheus will attempt to sacrifice
himself and that neo can save him but
only at the cost of his own life
when exiting the matrix morpheus and his
crew are betrayed by cipher and morpheus
throws himself at the machine's agent
enforcers to buy neo time to escape
however neo and trinity go back and
rescue him and neo is killed in the
attempt just as the oracle predicted but
revived shortly thereafter trinity
admits she loves neo and therefore he is
the one
trinity's belief revives neo and the
entire party escapes back to the real
world
neo and trinity build a romantic bond
that becomes key to the future of
humanity
the next time neo goes to visit the
oracle and the matrix reloaded he's
confronted by her bodyguard serif
serif is also a program possibly as old
as the oracle herself
those who seek a consultation with the
oracle must first fight seraph not to
defeat him but to demonstrate their
skills in the case of neo serif tests
him to determine whether or not he is
truly the one
seraph says that you do not truly know
someone until you fight them and while
this might just seem like an excuse for
a movie to add an extra fight scene it's
also clever that a program like the
oracle would restrict access via the
martial arts equivalent of a login page
however serif can also allow people
other than the one to visit the oracle
in enter the matrix serif submits other
resistant fighters to the same test and
they are each admitted to see her as
well
if someone demonstrates that they're
dedicated enough they can earn the right
to speak to the oracle
when neo visits the oracle in the matrix
reloaded he arrives with a much greater
understanding of the matrix and is able
to deduce that serif and the oracle are
programs rather than humans with special
abilities
the oracle implies she's in exile hiding
so she won't be deleted but this might
not be true while she operates
autonomously inside the matrix she's
still a part of the machine's system of
control since the cycle of the one
depends on her cooperation and so the
oracle instructs neo on how to reach the
source telling him this is quote where
the path of the one ends
the oracle doesn't lie to neo she only
gives exactly the information necessary
neo follows her advice and encounters
the architect learning the truth about
the prophecy of the one and the oracle's
role in creating the matrix
unlike his predecessors neo refuses to
participate in rebooting the matrix
since it means the death of his true
love trinity this is the oracle's design
by pairing neo and trinity she gives the
one something beyond human survival to
fight for
he chooses to break the cycle to save
trinity ensuring the machine war ends
one way or another
i know it
he's the one
the oracle is played by two different
actors and the matrix reloaded the
matrix revolutions and the game enter
the matrix the original oracle gloria
foster passed away before her scenes for
the rest of the series could be
completed
she was succeeded by mary alice who
co-starred as her sister in the play
having our say the matrix revolutions
acknowledges the casting change and
provides an in-universe explanation for
the oracle's new appearance that is
fleshed out and enter the matrix
in the game the oracle explains that her
choice to help neo has enraged the
merovingian a powerful exiled program
and the secondary antagonist of the
trilogy
among the merovingian's interests is
arranging for programs that have fallen
out of favor with the machine world to
hide out inside the matrix
he agrees to help the young program sati
reach the matrix only if her parents
kamala and ramacandra deliver him a
termination code that can destroy the
oracle's preferred physical appearance
this is mostly an act of spite but the
loss of her old body does seem to weigh
upon the oracle
neo and the oracle meet again in the
matrix revolutions
neo asks the oracle why she hid so much
of the truth from him and the oracle
replies it wasn't time
on this visit neo has specific questions
and the oracle has direct answers the
oracle wants the war to end and she's
been working toward this goal for a long
time now it's within reach and will
require the one to travel to the source
in the real world
the oracle isn't certain about the
details everything that's happening now
is new off track from the repeating
course of history and clouded by a
series of choices that neither she nor
neo can understand
another unexpected element is the
malevolent program called smith
originally assigned to protect the
status quo of the matrix smith has gone
rogue and presents a threat to humans
and machines smith has gained the
ability to rewrite other programs and
human avatars and is slowly taking over
the entire simulation the machine has no
control and neo is the only force
powerful enough to stop him
smith assimilates the oracle which
grants him her powers of foresight
however like the oracle he can't see
past a choice he doesn't understand
at the oracle's request neo journeys to
the machine city where the mainframe of
the matrix lives and programs are born
the machines are poised to wipe out all
of humanity but are in danger from smith
who has conquered the matrix neo offers
to go back into the matrix and defeat
smith
in exchange the machines must spare zion
and allow the human minds in the matrix
to escape if they choose the machines
accept neo's terms and he battles with
smith who has foreseen his own victory
smith finds himself standing over a
battered neo ready to deliver the
killing blow
when he becomes flustered he finds
himself repeating a phrase the oracle
once spoke to neo
everything that has a beginning has an
end
this final message from the oracle helps
neo understand the choice he needs to
make sacrifice himself to defeat the
enemy he allows smith to override his
code which gives the machines a way to
burn out the smith virus smith can't
understand this choice and therefore
walks into his own doom smith is
destroyed and everything he recoded is
restored including the oracle
the final scene of the original matrix
trilogy sees the oracle meet with the
architect to discuss the future of the
matrix the architect tells the oracle
she's quote played a very dangerous game
confirming that from his view she's been
the mastermind behind the entire
revolution
if the architect can be taken at his
word the next incarnation of the matrix
will allow for humans to choose to
accept the simulation and whether or not
to remain there
this change has been the oracle's goal
all along a hard-won victory in a
centuries-long chess match against the
architect she may not have known for
certain her plan would succeed but like
everything else in the matrix her
victory hinged on her belief in the
cause and in neo
this newfound peace can't be sustained
forever as unrest would eventually
return to the matrix both in the video
game sequel the matrix online and the
matrix resurrections
what role the oracle will play in the
future remains to be seen hidden by
narrative choices we don't yet
understand
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the matrix are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you